in the center of our solar system
there's a ticking time bomb and when it
explodes it will end all life on Earth
that time bomb is our sun and like all
the stars in the universe it has an
expiration date some 5 billion years
from now it will swell into a red giant
obliterating everything in its vicinity
including you if you think that's bad
you ain't seen nothing yet here are 10
doomsday events that will end the world
small asteroids are hitting Earth all
the time but once every few million
years it's a massive life Exterminating
asteroid that smashes into our planet
yeah that's happened before when
dinosaurs got wiped out of existence
only now it would be you and all of
humanity becoming extinct the earth's
core is a scorching ball of fire as hot
as the sun and it's slowly but surely
losing its blazing heat when the core
cools down it'll stop generating Earth's
magnetic field and without a
magnetosphere there would be nothing to
protect us from hostile space radiation
and there would be nothing to hold our
atmosphere in place either once our
planet lost most of its breathable air
it would start looking a lot like Mars
if the moon broke off its orbit and
suddenly went spiraling down to earth it
would cause devastating earthquakes all
over our planet our moon's gravity would
make earth stretch and heat up on the
inside and this would trigger massive
volcanic eruptions
add to that monstrous waves that would
wipe out entire coastlines all these
disasters would last until the moon
reached the Roche limit then it would
break into millions of small pieces
creating a magnificent ring around a
lifeless Rock we call Earth the next
doomsday event will start with a massive
explosion on the sun's surface a solar
flare so powerful that it will zap the
Earth's atmosphere this would hit
satellites and damage our Electronics
some 12 hours later a cloud of scorching
plasma would cause a serious geomagnetic
storm down on earth a global power
outage will plunge human civilization
Into Darkness who knows how long will
last when all our power grids are
destroyed
Earth is slowly losing its atmosphere to
space and when there's no breathable air
left on our planet Humanity won't stand
a chance without the atmosphere the sky
will turn black oceans will start to
boil away everything will be about to
die as All Earth's oxygen vents out into
space life doesn't do so well in a
vacuum do Jupiter is made of the same
elements as the sun and if the gas
planet could initiate a fusion reaction
in its core we'd all be doomed Jupiter
turned star would make the solar system
go wild asteroids would smash into
planets planets would smash into each
other this new star could pull Earth
toward it and toast it like a
marshmallow or it could spit us out of
the solar system and send us drifting
into the cold darkness of space
magnetars are the most powerful spinning
magnets in the universe they're similar
to neutron stars only a lot denser one
tablespoon of magnetar weighs in at one
billion tons if a magnetar entered our
solar system it would wreak havoc with
its immense gravity but that isn't the
worst magnetars experience star Quakes
that's when stars cry crack and let out
tons of radiation into space this much
radiation would rip the Earth's ozone
layer into shreds and obliterate the
planet's surface
along with all life on it of course
aliens visiting Earth could be a dream
come true but it can quickly turn into
your worst nightmare if they just showed
up on our doorstep and we decided to
throw our nukes at them you know as a
defensive measure of well this would get
ugly quick alien Intruders would likely
have way more advanced weapons to use
against us and even if they did turn out
to be friendly alien species could
easily wipe us out by spreading
pathogens that we'd have no natural
immunity to okay there are two things
you need to know about black holes one
they're massive and two you don't want
Earth to end up in one because that
would suck if a black hole was going to
swallow Earth it's monstrous gravity
would stretch our planet
Earth's closest side would get the most
pull and the opposite side would be
pulled less this is what
spaghettification looks like and then we
would get squished into the black holes
Singularity becoming one with our
Devourer there is no explosion in the
universe more violent than a gamma-ray
burst just one Direct Hit to Earth would
instantly incinerate the planet our
ozone layer would go poof and you'd be
bathed in a lethal dose of radiation
this would be a horrifying mass
extinction event and that's why it made
it to the top of our list of the most
devastating events that will end the
world